j'avais des guerres d'aujourd'hui
non merci jean luc nancy je suis pas
dans la pub non plus bercy
est ce que voulait une question ah oui
ah oui c'est à dire ça c'est ce qu'il
fait ce jeu wii et regarde tout ce qui
se passe en off dans l'émission et nous
en met plein la tête je ne pourrai
toujours moyen âge pour résumer on y va
la première question bonjour je
m'appelle françoise dans vos questions à
cafetière vous avez montré que gilles
verdez idolâtre enora malagré est il
vraiment sincère et si oui est il un peu
con sur les bords foncés jeu je peux
vous l'affirmer gilles et sincère il
admire vraiment enora enfin le jeu si
non c'est pas le soin mais franchement
ça se voit qu'ils aiment bien parce
qu'il ya des petits détails qu'il
trahisse alors vous le savez depuis
mardi dernier
nous savons que j voudrais bien frapper
matthieu delormeau alors rassure-toi
mathieu tu n'es pas le seul regardez
bien ces gestes avant l'émission
quand on énonce le nom de ses collègues
vous avez voté mais non je pense qu'il a
une petite préférence arrêts alors que
trouve gilles a une aura enfin je veux
dire
l'étoile et nohra le l'oeuvre d'art et
c'est pas méchant de poser la question
parce que même elle elle est un peu
largué devant tant de dévotion admirer
n'est pas je suis con comme un malaise
si si si elle te dis quel écho comme un
balai c'est mieux que toi comme il est
des sujets il aime pas il veut pas
entendre ça 1
gilles est un homme droit objectif mais
ils perdent tout sens commun avec sa
voisine
c'est bizarre parce qu'en plus c'est
fait rien du tout pour l'énerver
jamais le souci quant à des gros nibards
les regarde maman ne pas défaillir près
ce que j'aime c'est que les candidats
ils en seraient ces quotas attention au
total le garder dans le problème de
nibards en fait je nomme je crois que
son admiration prendra et juste
inversement proportionnelle à
l'admiration qu'il a pour le faire il
n'y a pas de vent mais qu'est ce qu'un
fan de façade bien
je kiffe
mais regardez il vit la musique de face
à professionnels du marketing c'est le
terrain on nous vend des dj
oh oui répondent non répondait lui non
mais je vais pas lui répondre
pas pour des leçons à tout le monde et
dans le dos des gens il parlait tout
sauf un professionnel du marketing
j'aime la musique et je la vis et je
vois pas qu'est ce qui est autorisé à
dire ça c'est choquant même un nom bien
continue loris tu as bien pour continuer
la route
moi je ne trouve pas ça a calmé vous ça
va je perdais du temps je vais commencer
on est en tout cas
gilles verdez où ils disent qu'ils
pensent à moi je les invite à regarder
ma ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie
musicalement et après de parler et aux
salins c'est vrai c'est facile de faire
ça non mais producteurs de diam's quand
même c'est bon je voulais je vous dise
vous savez pourquoi je suis content moi
franchement g20 dit parce que grâce à
gilles verdez on a réussi à réveiller te
fare ça fait quand même un non cotisées
lagat qui dort là bas dans le coin et au
bout de voilà presque la fin de la
saison il s'est réveillé il ouvre un
oeil
c'est pas évident allez j'ose plus faire
la suite
l'arrivée le cours ne te fady khallouf
bon heureusement tout le monde n'est pas
comme gilles verdez un jean-michel par
exemple ils adorent isabelle même s'il
est trop pudique pour les faire des
compliments face non jean michel cohen
un truc sympa à dire sur isa maïs
tourner vers thierry la pudeur et c'est
là que l'araignée m'a piqué je me suis
concentré sur moi c'est pas vrai donc ça
va mieux là ça va mieux ça ça dégonfle
et au moins mais c'est fou une araignée
juste à la trouver tout vous
oh là là ça m'a fait rire à hilal prend
tout bien c'est un amour c'est isabelle
où ma chérie d'amour alors pour
continuer dans la joie et l'allégresse
oui lors des avant dernières concierge
avait montré les mimiques d'isabelle
regardant un magnéto alors pour ceux qui
l'auraient oublié un tir un peu mais
c'est vous c'est quand vous appuyez vous
savez sur le sont plusieurs fois sur la
chaîne vous appuyez 8 plusieurs fois
sassafras que vous avez on se rappelle
tous amano d'après vous quelle tête fait
isabelle quand elles se regardent faire
des grimaces dans les quatre tiers doit
faire corps des green et baal et la mise
en abyme du jour il s'appelle morini
bosc a je crois que c'est encore pire
tout seul la semaine dernière nous
recevions label anastacia qui a avant de
quitter le plateau a voulu embrasser
ceux qui avaient participé au concours
de sosies oui mais ça gérard louvin
l'avaient pas compris et c'est comme ça
qu'on se prend un gros vent ça fait du
bien
des rivages
on va s'intéresser pour calmer les
esprits un cyril liban ya quelques
semaines je vous avais promis dans cette
rubrique de vous livrer quelques secrets
sur sur l'intimité de notre guide à tous
que vous connaissiez mieux ce soir c'est
pas ce ferry qui vous révèle un secret
c'est isabelle à place à la magie
mais il est il à la transmission je
trouve je tends fallait je t'en supplie
s'intéresse que je peux penser
et là bim casquette accroché à son
traitement de rigoler ils avaient trouvé
son sac une intro
les grès raku cello diallo je suis
descendu à la station auber
non mais alors ils venaient dans tinfos
sexe n'est pas faux sexe mais c'est
dommage car il aime bien s'amuser avec
sa baguette à harry potter une question
on y va bonjour je m'appelle jacqueline
je regarde souvent votre rubrique et je
me pose une vraie question est ce qu'un
jour sans le faire exprès jean michel mr
a dit un truc intelligent
c'est une vraie question qui se pose est
la jacqueline mais j'ai pas pu tous des
rochers j'ai visionné pour l'instant 244
émission et je dis toujours pas trouvé
une chose intelligente dit en off
il a dû en dire mais mais comme il parle
très bas ben ça va pas non heureusement
syrie lui rappellent chaque jour
d'élever le taux sérique trouve pas je
parle plus fort
la radio non mais sérieux trou pages
paru fort le pkk
céline a toujours les mots qui encourage
la semaine dernière à l'événement pour
jean-michel c'était évidemment la venue
sur notre plateau de la sublime eva
longoria et quand je dis événement c'est
est-ce que la veille de sa venue il a eu
un peu de mal à cacher sa joie
jean-michel à demain à 18h30 en direct
on démarrera l'émission tenez vous bien
avec eva longoria
m
sexuellement je présiderai retracer
cette rencontre exceptionnelle voilà
sont là qui n'a pas bouleversé l'univers
des people à tout jamais nous sommes le
mardi 13 mai il est 18h 27
jean michel est en plateau eva est en
coulisses jean-michel se prépare
mais revenons à venance dans le public
il est au bout du rouleau
le gentleman est toujours là 19h10 face
à eva jean-michel doit servir de
punching ball humains et vente profité
pour montrer bac que c'est un [ __ ] de
comédien donc c'est perdu eva mais la
fracasser le faites moi plaisir j'aime
les challenges en est persuadé il a
marqué des points
ouais les vannes n'a pas été séduite que
par l'homme elle a aussi été séduite par
l'artiste alors avant qu'elle ne quitte
le plateau il me demande une photo pour
immortaliser cette rencontre dans sa
tête c'est déjà gagné
je suis sûr que ma photo avec angoisse
la top tweets dialogue côté monde va
tomber fou de toi est pas tombé près de
toi
comme je dois arriver là mais carey
n'est pas sérieux je me connais par
coeur
et non je sais qu'un appel si j'étais
malade ni son sort il est parti 11e
place on a envie se moquer mais pour une
fois je vais être complètement honnête à
les lui rendre hommage parce que contre
toute attente notre programmateur invité
christian perry vient le voir la pause
pub suivante et lui révèle qu eva a fait
appeler son assistante pour avoir son
ombre vous allez voir quand jean michel
est content il fait des crises avec sa
bouche d'état les bruits bizarres
m
du lot c'est le diva cyril femmes et ba
et ba elle m'a pas demandé l'aide de la
question
des chroniques à nantes du chroniqueur
l'assistante a rappelé pour sam en mon
nom
j'en passe
dépêchez-vous recharge de ronger de
match je lui dis t'es pas encore au
bourget mon chéri c'est pas encore au
bourget mon chéri comme un choix je suis
allé il a le triomphe modeste mais bravo
bravo il a réussi à séduire eva longoria
c'est christian qui l'a révélé c'est
vrai alors on en est ou alors cette
affaire bah je sais pas si tu vivras
suit à peu ou pas ah bah non ça connaît
pas la suite
non mais la suite c'est que ce gentil
nom alors je vais lire la suite parce
que parce qu'il vaut mieux vous me voir
la suite franchement je m'en suis pas
remis de sa donc le lendemain j'en
parlais encore avec cyril
jean de la
c'est brice hortefeux les mains
je
l'équipe
je suis désolé parce que jouer qui
allait révéler ça mais en fait c'est
parce qu'ils voulaient dire en baisse
parce que tout ce que tu veux pas dire
croyez qu'il avait donné mon ancien
numéro du coup c'est pour ça qu'elle me
rappelais pas raconter à tout le monde
tous parviennent pas à passer
c'était le but mais vous savez que ça
peut partir de là ça peut se retourner
pour une émission de radio en parlant de
sanofi qui croyaient vraiment différent
passer pour un con dont il a acquis ces
[ __ ] c'est ça que je vais me faire
pardonner j'ai pas on va pas se quitter
là dessus pour pas finir sur cette
déception je vais montrer une dernière
image de jean-michel beaucoup plus
valorisant à rose mais je vais vous le
dire c'est mon image favorite de la
semaine voilà
fini ce matin
j
bon